hello we are here with Naomi Wolf the
author of the end of America a letter
warning to a young Patriots this wolf of
course comes to this conversation very
well-qualified as a public intellectual
and the book is a fascinating reading
book and this the back cover is says the
end of America will shock and rage and
motivate let me start by asking you what
is it that in probe you to drive this
book to write this book
yeah with thank you for a very personal
reason I teach young leaders at an
institute that I co-founded and we of
course we young Americans to be well
educated in democracy and passionate
about the founders vision and I was
mentoring a young woman named Jennifer
ganden a wonderful young woman she was
married marrying a wonderful young man
named Chris Lee and I was reading
histories of closing societies at the
time and at Jennifer and Chris's wedding
I realized that the storm clouds were
really gathering if I didn't give them a
gift and really give their peers a gift
which nobody really seems to be giving
them of a guideline so the user's guide
to democracy in in easy to understand
accessible language a kind of shortcut
to the founders vision and it not only
that but also a kind of primer for how
societies have closed down in the past
how democracies have been undermined in
the past because what I was seeing
around me was a series of very
recognizable systematic assaults on
through the the key things that we need
to sustain a strong democracy and just
to share why this is like especially
profound for me as a mother I have
children and you know I want them to
grow up free we all want our kids to
grow up free obviously and Christmas
story is especially poignant and the
reason you know I thought of him too
much was writing because when his mom
was 28 which is his age now
she took her four-month-old baby his
name was
who and fled Vietnam and became a boat
person refugee to risk her life in her
baby's life to come to this country
because and this is so moving to me when
I met her I was so impressed with her
she such a true American you know in
this in that the best ends of the
founders vision she really understood
Liberty the way the founders would have
wanted all of us to understand Liberty
and it was moving to me as a mother to
think that she would have made the
decision to risk her life so that her
child could grow up free and so it just
seems so important to honor that by
writing a primer for for young people
relief for all Americans about how to
defend democracy when its undress called
and to recognize the warning signs of
pressure on democracy that can really
close it down the registry shows can be
very effective it's a very very
interesting primer and an introduction
to the nub to the book I'm most
interested when I first started reading
through it as an academic by where you
start off with respect to sort of state
of academia and the role of patriotism
and freedom in in that world so if I may
I'll read a quick little excerpt here at
page 27 and you write in colleges with
progressive curricula the founders the
framers our Constitution are often
portrayed as quote dead white men whose
vision was imperfect who deny women and
port and the poor civil rights who
define in African slave in America is
being Priestess of a person old guys in
wigs who wrote documents are now dusty
in language that seems to us to be
neither are either arcane or to offer
sentiments that are so obvious they have
now become clichés and in many ways you
argue against this vision of the
founders take me through both of those
steps why do you think it is that in
progressive academia half there is this
a denigration of the framers and then
how do you go about espousing a project
to reaffirm their relevance into in
today's society I'm so glad you're
asking that question and this is I just
want to say this is why this is why I
love a working democracy because I think
you and I may come from not the same
place in the political spectrum but this
is a suitable and right
conversation to have and my liberal
colleagues aren't asking it of me so I
value this it's really important the
right has made a ton of mistakes in the
colonizing of patriotism as my country
right or wrong I don't think that's what
the founders intended at all and the
debate was vigorous in you know in their
day as you know better than I do you
know people I think you know people were
using strong language in talking to the
opposition and they were valuing the
free exchange of ideas so that was the
rights mistake that the left made their
own mistakes horrible mistakes so that
when I speak to young people today
across the country a a lot of them don't
know what democracy is a horrible study
just came out showing that even Harvard
freshmen don't really understand basic
civics or basic checks and balances
there's like real civic illiteracy they
don't teach civics anymore in many
jurisdictions I think Maryland no longer
teaches middle school or civics so we're
going to democracy a literate class of
young people but the left also horribly
in the 60s embraced kind of the tenets
of post-market ISM and a kind of Marxist
analysis may be useful for finding out
what's wrong with driving economic
motivators but it's horrible if you're
trying to value eighteenth-century both
liberal and conservative ideals of the
freedom of the individual the rights of
men eventually the rights of women those
ideas became very old-fashioned on the
left and and no one was teaching young
people who inherited this left-wing
intellectual framework that it wasn't
Marxism that's the most radical thing on
earth the most radical thing on earth is
what the framers put in place which is
this unbelievably transformative ideal I
mean no one teaches it to us as
passionately amazingly revolutionary
anymore that they decided you know what
let's move further out into the unknown
in a vision of giving ordinary people
autonomy ordinary people the power to
make decisions about their lives and
their communities and and so there's no
kind of glamorization of the democratic
project and
last thing which is truly bad is that
identity politics did you know it's a
legitimate critique the framers weren't
superheroes and they weren't profits and
they didn't have you know a vision that
transcended their century in their time
so yeah they blew it they left out you
know they left out people of color they
left out women they left out we didn't
have a threshold of a certain amount of
property but that was so much further
than anyone had ever gone before that
and what is miraculous to me is that
other groups have demanded the expansion
of democracy without having to
fundamentally transform what the
founders set in motion so we really need
to teach young people this issue
transcends left and right you know
that's why I'm getting so much support
from conservatives as well as liberals
who are alarmed about what they see
going on to democracy we need to kind of
relearn you know the standard division
kind of fall in love with it again
because the last thing that happened
which is bad to your questions point is
that all of us old and young left and
right kind of got lazy and we kind of
subcontracted out defending democracy or
understanding the Constitution to a
professional class you know it's like oh
the accounter will do my taxes the
landscape guy will do the lawn you know
the politicians will do democracy the
pundits will talk about democracy or the
constitutional scholars will understand
the Constitution and that is not what
the founders intended that is so so an
abdication and it's set in place the
danger we're seeing now it made it
possible for people to strip away our
freedoms the founders intended for you
and me not just you you are a
constitutional scholar but me a citizen
a non-lawyer
you know the person teaching my kids the
person who's doing the lawn the founders
intended for us to understand the
Constitution the Bill of Rights for us
to defend it for us to do freedom to
maintain democracy and you comment in
the book that this democracy is fragile
and needs to be refreshed I think you
quote Thomas Jefferson that there needs
to be a revolution of generation or so
or at least certainly just of his of his
idea that we need to refresh our
understanding of the common
Constitution uh do you think that that
project is especially necessary at this
time and why well I do for very
disturbing reasons another person I
talked about a younger person who led me
to want to write this book an older
person also led me to one of my dear
friends is a slightly older mentor of
mine who is the daughter of Holocaust
survivors and she kept saying to me and
I'm Jewish so I don't take this lightly
at all my grandparents lost relatives in
the Holocaust
she kept saying to me as we were reading
news event they did this in Germany they
did this in Germany and I thought she
was insane you know or at least
hyperbolic and she had seen any pics in
German agents in Germany she's not
talking about the horrific nightmare
outcomes of you know 1938 1939 she was
talking about the early years when
Germany was still working parliamentary
democracy fragile besieged on all sides
the working parliamentary democracy with
newspapers and human rights lawyers and
Bauhaus and fashion and celebrities and
a lot of the things we find recognizable
today and she insisted that I sit down
and start reading history of the early
years the years and everyone's looking
around thinking surely as a time pass
this can't fate this can't no we won't
stay up to this surely they can't get
worse than this and the more I started
reading first the history of the early
years the pressure on this gradual
democracy the stripping of that
Constitution and the closing down of
those civil liberties and then when I
started reading the other great tyrants
and how Mussolini kind of pioneered the
closing down of a fragile democracy in
the 20s and then Hitler studied
Mussolini and not then I looked at the
30s in Germany and then I looked at
install and studied Hitler and Hitler
study too-tall and I looked at Stalin
the end of the 30s and then I looked at
East Germany in the 50s and
Czechoslovakia in 1968
Pinochet's coup in Chile in 1973 the
Chinese cracked down on the democracy
movement at the end of the 80s early 90s
what became clear is that would be death
spits on the left or the right no matter
where they are in the world always think
this in
ten key steps they always do the same
ten things systematically it's like a
blueprint for closing down a democracy
and the early tyrants the great tyrants
kind of developed it this technology and
then petty tyrants tyrants all over
Latin America for instance we're looking
at what's happening in yanma right now
on you know Pakistan they all can study
it and know what to do to close down
democracy or crush a pro-democracy
uprising so it was very disturbing to me
that as I read these histories it was
clear that we're seeing a scene ten
steps in America today and the most the
most dramatic and recent repetition of
those ten steps on the world stage you
recount in a paragraph in your book was
the generals takeover of the the
government in Thailand and you recount
all the steps they did in while the
Prime Minister was was out of the
country and still I believe is still in
exile you know you see these kinds of
steps very blatant and it comes from the
area of a world in which I come from and
have a natural affinity to do so I find
it particularly relevant and yet we
don't hear about it that much and the
international community doesn't waste
too much ink or the or consternation
over these kinds of breaking over the
use of patient of democratic processes
why do you think that is well
unfortunately we've got some not great
karma in the United States right now I
mean essentially and it's putting us in
jeopardy what I mean is we've been in a
bubble we you know we're affluent we you
know we're internet shopping or watching
America's Next Top Model everything's
okay here at home and so we're living
what I call a democracy mess which is
the envy the works of saying well we're
the exception to the rest of the world
we don't need to worry about treaties on
global warming we're America we don't
need to worry about if the rest of the
world starts to hate us because we're
abusing prisoners in say rocky hills
prisons and stripping them of their
rights and holding their families
hostage we don't need to worry about
that because we're America and so we're
it's this myth that we're walking around
in which the founders have been
horrified at that democracy will always
protect us and that
what closes down open societies overseas
could never happen here and so just as
you say paradoxically so ironically we
don't look at what's going on in
Pakistan and what's you know we don't
see the warning signs of oh my gosh in
China you know Yahoo turned over
people's internet search records because
we don't understand that that could
happen to us too and we need to be alert
and we need to make good on our promise
to be a beacon of democracy around the
world we need to say you know we are not
going to tolerate it that you're going
to round up the opposition in Egypt and
put them in prison round up bloggers in
Egypt were you know we're advocating our
role as the benchmark the light units
sitting on the hill and so the paradox
is the Comets coming back to us which is
that around the world democracy
activists look at us making it easier
for the President of the United States
to declare martial law for the President
of the United States to say to or his
lawyers are arguing that he can say you
or to me innocence as we are you're an
enemy combatant and put us in solitary
confinement make it difficult for us to
communicate with a lawyer wait for
months or years before files are charged
charges are filed and psychiatrists know
that solitary confinement makes sane
healthy people like us crazy
sooner or later okay you know these are
blinking red lights to democracy
activists around the world it's like
hello
you know warrantless wiretapping hello a
security apparatus a news ten steps are
so recognizable to democracy activists
around the world and so the not great
karma is because we didn't worry about
other people's democracy
we're not educated enough about the
crazily classic warning signs of threats
to democracy that we're seeing all
around us right now let me get right to
the right to the heart of your of your
criticism of the current climate in
America and in large part you lay the
blame at the administration executive
branch's response to 9/11 both in
meeting aftermath and certainly now
several years going on but is it just
the administration because you take for
example the question of an income enemy
that combatant Congress has passed
statutes which you criticized you
criticize the Supreme Court no less than
justice o'connor's written for ADA for a
federally liberal grouping that affirms
the president's private power maintain
you know obviously but requires certain
process fees that up to that point had
not been given to the to these detainees
but certainly at the court reaffirming
the president's power to detain under
the Constitution in law enemy combatants
who is the threat now is it the
president is the Congress is it the
court and are you in danger of crying
wolf against everybody that we used to
call the man without that we're very
very easily specifying who exactly is
the enemy within to democracy in your
eyes right well I think I'm pretty
specific identifying exactly what the
steps are and what the dangers are and
what the real tipping point actions are
and I think it was a tipping point when
the United States Congress agreed to let
the state essentially torture people and
its control that was one of those
tipping points if you follow closing
societies you recognize you never want
to give the state that power because I
invite you you're so scholarly you're so
well educated I invite you to name and
nobody has been able to do this yet
because there isn't one as far as I know
a society to create a network of secret
prisons for torture takes place with
States not eventually end up turning
some of those tactics of abuse on
domestic toxic what my understanding
both with respect to congressional
action and believe me I've been very
critical both of Congress in certain
respect of the administration about some
of these areas especially with respect
to end combatants enough of your
citizens but to be very clear that that
to be very clear I keep my conversations
private to be very clear the United
States is a signatory to the anti
torture convention there is a there is a
legislation prohibiting the torture is
the official policy of United States
officials that we that we don't worry
to create the official policy you know
on the gates of Auschwitz and and the
and and and the question and the
question is are we ascribing
responsibility of where we are where you
are not where are you ascribing
responsibility where that they don't
really be are deserving because we still
are trying to however imperfectly and
there will always be mistakes because
the system is that made up humans live
up to the ideals and the law
specifically Against Torture there there
are basically what is cruel and unusual
cruel and inhuman treatment and the like
but at the core we can all agree that we
don't torture no we can't agree that at
all and you are you're such an honorable
decent man and you come from a place
where the state rounds people up and
tortures them and I'm very sorry that
you're I'm very sorry that you're
repeating the administration line and
soundbite that we don't torture when
human rights organizations know
perfectly well that we're torturing
people in our custody and have you know
for years
Abu Ghraib bad episode clearly illegal
people being held accountable through
the process not adequate you know you
know so much better than if I don't want
to waste time with this important than
you
rebutting administration sound bites
that are essentially falsehood anyone
who wants to read the end of America can
see for themselves what Michael Ratner
who represents the detainees and what
other human rights organizations know
and have proven again and again about
the horrific horrific sickening abuse
that people like you and me who descend
from people who were held and mistreated
abuse should not be descending but let
me sort of hope you rethink that but let
me go back to your question about
Congress you're right you're absolutely
right this Democratic Congress and and
the Congress that that supported these
initial measures will go down in history
with great shame and great blackening of
their name and I'm sorry to say I think
the defenders of what the administration
is doing to the detainees will also go
down in history to great shame for the
following reason and again histories so
instructive if you look
at the rice said the Parliament in
Germany that made it possible for the
National Socialists to legally come to
power they were elected Americans forget
they were elected and they said they
wasn't anarchy
they systematically brilliantly used the
law to pervert the law National
Socialist Germany was a nation of laws
proliferating laws expanding laws that
legalize torture that had been nearly
gone si basements that turned to
prosecute human rights lawyers that said
wait a minute don't abuse of detainees
and and it was the Congress that
preceded Hitler that stripped it you
know passed the Enabling Act the past
Clause 2 which is very much echoes the
patriot act as you know a foreshadows it
as you know and that weakens the
Constitution so substantially that and
they weren't lofty they were
conservative favorite people like you
know you and your friends you know where
me and my friends really cared about
Germany they cared about democracy but
in the name of patriotism it because
they were being told there are
terrorists and this is a standard tactic
that would-be dictators invoke a real
terrorist threat there were real
terrorists in Germany there were armed
Bolsheviks and you know there was an
allegation that an armed terrorist had
set fire to Parliament which is the
equivalent of setting fire to you know
the Capitol and so Germans were
terrified there were reports that were
being sent out that there would be worse
terrorist attacks on infrastructure
people were scared that the water supply
would be blown up that that you know
subways would be blown up and they were
petrified and so in the name of
patriotism the people elected parliament
passed Clause 2 and passed the Enabling
Act which then opened the door for the
abuses to come so I'm not even saying
it's bush is bush with the compliance of
a craven submissive Congress and and
history will shame them because off the
record all these people are coming up to
us and saying you know what I'm
horrified at the dismantling of the
Constitution and horrified at the
stripping of these checks and balances
but I'm scared to say anything because
I'll be painted as soft on terror and
they have got to know that
despot after death but after despot has
invoked that step number one invoke an
internal and external threat they start
all of them view by invoking either
pretend or real terrorist threat to
terrify people that their makes it
easier for them to do what they're going
to do Stalin did this with sleeper cells
he told everyone that there were
capitalist agents in hiding in Russia
that we're going to rise up at a signal
and create havoc we've heard the term
sleeper cells recently and that was a
fake threat but Pinochet is you must
know invoked a real terrorist threat
armed insurgents there really were armed
insurgents and used fake documentation
we've seen fake documentation presented
by the White House to justify to hide
the terror threat and he call it Plan Z
and he said that they were going to
assassinate military leaders all at once
and Chileans were so terrified by this
hyped real threat that they submitted
and saw their democracy crushed um
several question that jumps to mind let
me start first with the this
conversation and throughout your book
you make repeated references to a
comparison with the Nazi Germany and and
you explain in your definition it was a
very deliberate choice of words you call
it the fascist shift or the shift toward
fascism and you recount a conversation
you had with other interlocutors about
the weather authority and all
totalitarian or or fascist you know my
first my first impression you know is
this what people talk about in Martha's
Vineyard because it seems to me a fairly
esoteric conversation but can you take
it can you take me through your thought
process and your choice of the direct
comparison as to where we are today and
where Nazi Germany was before and during
the sure sure what time is that that's a
very good question I mean first of all
you know I wish I was vacationing right
and so that little kind of you know like
like demographic kind of mockery doesn't
actually apply to me but of what you
should know in terms of I have great
respect for people and whether has been
right in fact that we should know
actually epical that is
hearing from ordinary Americans who
don't say keishon Martha's Vineyard who
are firefighters and police officers and
teachers and you know factory workers is
that it's not an esoteric conversation
at all they're looking around and they
are terrified and when I tell them that
this is a blueprint and I start naming
the ten steps you start with an external
and internal threat you create some
great prison systems where torture takes
place you create military tribunals I'm
sure that the people right now who are
supporting the new military tribunal
system going forward must not be aware
that when initiated a military tribunal
system Stalin imitated Lenin Mussolini
developed his own with a continuous
system Hitler ultimately Russia an ally
also the same thing but also have the
same military tribunal not including the
US including the Nuremberg trial is a
Military Commission yeah well let's get
into neural Virchow in a minute because
how profound it is to look at the
difference between how America showcases
democratic values by translating all
those documents into German televising
the trial making those the worst
terrorists on the planet fully
transparent to the world and showcasing
American justice compared to what we're
doing now the shame and the disgrace of
processing people and putting pressure
on two military attorney the question is
no community putting pressure on
military attorneys to sell out their
clients and enter river deltas
so is your objection not to the fact of
military tribunals but how it is being
processed and the procedures adopted
there under as being not a satisfactory
oh yes of course that these military
tribunals are set up the way that
military tribunals were in enclosing
societies to essentially make it
virtually impossible for the prisoner to
get a fair trial a fair hearing but
that's why the Supreme Court has stepped
in at various places and continues to
step in within the last several years in
order to impose procedures and limit the
government's discretion at the same time
recognizing the Corps that in a time of
war in the time of threat the the press
and the Congress gets significant
deference with respect to these to these
procedures that is the Supreme Court
also complicit in the Sunnah
in Japan I think the Supreme Court
should really I think what we are all in
in America is a state of kind of reptile
brain television that makes it very very
difficult for us to take a scene wide
view the way other modern democracies
are doing let me give you an example in
England Gordon Brown has said fighting
terror terror is a crime not a cause and
they have sustained horrific terrorist
attacks for years the same bad guys that
we're fighting and they are not using
that as an excuse to crack down on civil
liberties let's look at Spain Spain also
experienced a horrible horrible terror
attack same bad guys and they are trying
those accused in a transparent
transparent process using that trial to
uphold and showcase democracy you can
see the transcripts on the internet so
yeah I think all of us the courts
Congress and the executives have to kind
of snap out of this nightmare and and
look at history and uphold democratic
principles now let me just answer your
question about what you know is this an
esoteric conversation so the evoking of
an internal external threat the military
tribunals in the secret prisons
paramilitary force you love the founders
vision or else you wouldn't be doing
what you do and you know better than I
do that when you've got a paramilitary
force like Blackwater they've just got
in trouble for shooting innocent
civilians in Iraq and most Americans
don't realize Blackwater is now in the
United States that the home Department
of Homeland Security contracted to have
Blackwater personnel patrolling the
streets of New Orleans and Jeremy
Scahill reports that contractors not
necessarily Blackwater but other private
contractors were shooting at civilians
in New Orleans most Americans don't know
that the future business model of
Blackwater's to expand its operations
here at home with among other things
threats to public order and most
Americans don't realize now the
president has the power to define what
the threat to public order now the
president has the power to
call the National Guard over the
objections of one governor and send them
to restore public order in another state
something that if standards will be
horrified by because they knew the
damage that can be done when there's a
standing army that can break into your
home harass you curtail civil society
scare civilians molest women right you
know what a violation of our principles
that is the fourth step that create a
surveillance apparatus into ordinary
citizens we have that now the Washington
Post just reported that you know when
you get on a plane now not you but me
and it creates the administration but
maybe you too because there is no safety
in a clothing Society no matter what
your politics they're keeping track of
what you're reading on the plane and
who's sitting next to you and who you're
going to go visit and what their phone
number is and it's in East Germany a
majority of the citizens weren't being
watched by the Stasi only a minority
were but all it took was knowing that
the Stasi were watching you to subdue a
whole population you know the fifth step
is to infiltrate harass citizen groups
and the ACLU has many lawsuits under way
that that's happening so that key part
of democracy being able to gather with
your neighbors and say and I'm not happy
about the war I am happy about the war
you know now there are agents among us
watching what we say and what we do the
sixth step is to arbitrary detain and
what these citizens this gets really
disturbing because and again at the
classic fashion
tactic in our youth fascist quite
conservatively I use it according to the
dictionary definition of when the state
starts to use force against an
individual in an effort to close down
democratic processes must mean that you
can't say we're not seeing that if the
president can hold you or me in a cell
intelligent employment for months or
years the state has that power now but I
was on the TSA watchlist so that every
time I got on a plane I would get this
quadruple a security clearance a
security warning on my ticket and
finally I asked this nice young woman
who was searching me you know why does
this keep happening she said you're on
the list the list and then and you know
I don't think I fit a terrorist profile
and then I started researching it
turns out that other people who are on
the watch list are Richard Murphy the
great constitutional scholar of
Princeton who had just given a speech
being critical of the president
stripping of the Constitution
he had his luggage ransacked actually
destroyed and he was warned that he was
on the list to nice middle-aged ladies
who published a news magazine called war
times in San Francisco there on the list
one of the senior people Greenpeace is
on the list two members of the ACLU
staff are on the list I just got a call
from a legal adviser at who had been at
the Justice Department who said that
she's on the list and that she's on the
watch list every time she flies and she
said I said what did you do she said I
told my colleagues don't torture John
Walker Lindh and make sure you have a
lawyer because we interrogate him and
she said I had to do that I was the
ethics advisor that was my job I'm a
lawyer and she said they did torture him
and they did interrogate him without a
lawyer present and then when I objected
my emails got cleared and there was a
criminal investigation against me she
said and they reported me to the Bar
Association she said and now she's on
the watch list and I just got another
email from David altoon who's a senior
guy in the military who was critical of
the ward he and his family are on the
watch list so I could keep moving
through the last four steps although
they're very disturbing but I think you
and I can agree that that is not America
book is the edge of America the author's
Naomi Wolf will be right back in two
minutes
thank you afterwards and several other
c-span programs are available for
download as podcast visit book TV Norg
more with Naomi Wolf NB Ed's in in just
a moment
USA Today correspondent Barbara Slavin
says she got the title of her book when
an inebriated guest an event mixed up a
common expression in bitter friends
bosom enemies
she chronicles the frequently strained
relationship between the American and
Iranian government's looking at the fall
of the Shah
the 1979 hostage situation and the
possibility of Iran's involvement in
Iraq after the US invasion miss Levin
attempts to demystify the diplomatic
relationship between the two governments
afterwards with Barbara Slavin and
national Iranian American Council
President
treati Parsi next Sunday 6 p.m. Eastern
and Pacific only on book TV afterwards
with Naomi Wolf and Viet Dinh continues
we are back in our afterwards
conversation with Naomi Wolf the author
of the end of America letter of warning
to a young Patriot before we left you
were on step 6
yeah why don't you go ahead and continue
about the the rest of the ten steps that
you elucidate in your book thank you so
much so then the next step is to target
key individuals and you know this was a
very effective tactic that most both
Mussolini and a national socialists
developed of for example gurbles
purged the equivalent of PBS and NPR
when he got into power and then they put
pressure on academics in Italy and in
Germany at state institutions to
coordinate was the term with national
socialist ideology or if they lost their
jobs so people started key figures in
society and they were usually visible
performers entertainers editors and
journalists academics and opposition
leaders began to find that they would
face for years than job reprisal to job
loss if they didn't support the regime
in question then
increasingly criminal sanctions they
would get caught up in ever
proliferating laws that criminalize
speech for example and so more and more
kinds of speech became criminalized and
finally they were just rounded up and
arrested which is what would be
desperate as you know always do any
we're waiting for the shoe to drop in
Myanmar for those brave brave monks to
be mounted up and arrested on the
extraordinary courage that they have you
know we have to ask ourselves do we have
that courage because it's time for us to
be taking to the streets now well we're
still relatively safe and not later as
this process unfolds but so you look at
like dan Rather
who just filed a multi-million dollar
lawsuit against his employers because he
said that the White House pressured them
Viacom to dump him and that's the tactic
it's out of the 50s
certainly when Senator McCarthy was
pressuring CBS to fire people who didn't
support the hearings or who are critical
of the the red-baiting hearings but it's
also adapted from Italy and from Germany
the GE lawyers I mentioned earlier
they're so brave so brave these military
lawyers were sworn as lawyers are to
defend their clients and they're facing
a general Swift headed career derailed
because he wouldn't sell out his client
and many many people I just talked to
someone came up to me after reading
yesterday who works in government and he
said you know that we have to sign this
kind of loyalty oath now and I said what
you said yeah there's this basically
building a dossier on everyone and it's
like the identity card in Germany I
either sign it and let them go through
my banking records and check my credit
report and thought you know find out
everything they need to find out about
me
or else I don't have a job and I lose my
house so target key individuals and you
know I think about even people like Omar
who you know lost his job the Dixie
Chicks who had their their CDs burned
you know that scene of people burning
CDs well that's right out of gurbles
when he organized spontaneous
demonstrations of students to burn books
of people who were critical of the the
regime then what starts to happen is
that you restrict the press
and you're seeing more and more
criminalization speech in this country
just as you did in Germany in 1931-32
before Hitler as Chancellor and the
thing is very disturbing is for instance
Bill Keller the executive editor of the
New York Times when the Times published
the Swiss banking story there was a
drumbeat of calls that repeated the
talking points treason treason treason
now as you know one penalty for treason
substitution and Mellie Morgan actually
said that he should be charged with
treason and executed so since I was
reading Stalin at the time that gave me
chills because I knew that Nikolai
Bukharin
who was the publisher of his best year
the equivalent of the New York Times
actually was charged by Stalin with
treason for criticizing Stalin and was
actually executed for treason so you
know I try to be very conservative in my
argument I try to not say I know who's
doing this but what I think Americans
are smart and there are so many echoes
of that kind of not just tactics from
the past but actual language and imagery
and actually praying of certainty events
from the past you know two or three of
them as a coincidence but 30 and 40 and
50 and 60 including language and
metaphors
I think that's provocative and so I'm
you know very disturbed at the unive use
of the Espionage Act for instance the
invoking of the Espionage Act there was
this drum be of well charging with the
Espionage Act and again journalists in
Washington when they publish classified
material they are talking points where
people say charging under the Espionage
Act very scary because as you know but
most Americans don't know the last time
the 1917 Espionage Act was used was in
fact to round up people like I did want
to see you and me but certainly people
like me activists people who were you
know fighting against child labor
exploitation socialists teachers
anti-war critics journalists editors
Americans American citizens
putting them up without warrants right
putting an encryption with some of them
were beaten so that's not a happy sign
the invoking of 1917 Espionage Act
Eugene Debs got a ten year sentence
under the Espionage Act for giving a
speech about the Constitution and the
use of the Espionage Act at the end of
the teens silenced dissent in America
for a decade the last thing that you
start to see we're starting to see now
which is the recasting of criticism as
espionage and dissent as treason the
fact that the Senate voted to censure
move on I mean I didn't like that ad but
it is such a classic warning sign of a
closing society when the state starts to
censure speech and starts to target
organizations of dissidents for for
state censure and it was very disturbing
is you know Hillary Clinton but it could
be anyone
criticizing the war is called traitor
traitor traitor and if you look at
Stalin and if you look at Hitler and
what they did was that they began to
expand and expand the definition
terrorists and we're seeing that with
the rephrasing of sort of Animal
Liberation attacks against property as
terrorism there's expanded sentences but
you also start to see more and more
people and activities being called
treason
traitorous terrorism sabotage espionage
and the final step is to subvert the
rule of law and or to make it easier to
declare martial law and again activists
all over the world know what a foolish
mistake it is to pass something like the
2007 Defense Authorization Act that
gives the president it makes it easier
for him to declare martial law I think
even if one agrees with the
characterization of the ten steps the
natural question is why do you think the
threat is as imminent as you think that
it is to warrant a comparison of America
to Nazi Germany yeah and let me stress
again for people who are just paying
attention that I really want to stress
that what I'm looking at when I look at
Germany isn't not the outcome
it's not I'm not saying we're going to
have crematoria we're going to have you
know a regime you know that so far from
what I'm saying what I'm saying is much
more considered and very right which is
that there are certain tactics that have
been developed and are time-tested in
closing down a modern constitutional
democracy and there are two places where
this happened in Italy in Germany that
we can learn from and we're seeing if
you look at 1931 1932 the beginning of
1933 you'll see things recur and we owe
it to the victims of that Holocaust to
learn the lessons of history so and why
I think it's so urgent here's why it's a
very good question
what most people think is that democracy
is strong and so if there's a closing
down that it goes like this like a
diagonal line on a chart and that we've
got time to stabilize and react that's
not how it works
history shows that democracies close
down in a series of what Malcolm
Gladwell would call tipping points and
that when certain things start to happen
when certain tipping points have been
reached things start to close down very
fast so there was one such tipping point
when we legalized torture we don't have
to revisit that we did legalized torture
the second tipping point was when we
gave the president the right to say that
he can call any of us an enemy combatant
so what happens in a democracy under
sustained assault is that there will be
a sudden series of events the tasering
of that kid Andrew Meyer in Florida now
I wasn't surprised to find out that with
Florida because again I read gurbles
Gainesville is a state university state
universities answerable to a Board of
Regents the Board of Regents is
answerable to the state legislature
which is naturally verbal to Jeb Bush so
what you start along with over you know
Florida is a scene of many many kinds of
systemic defenses of these power grabs
by people who are supportive of this
administration of their goals and what
you know what you must know from closing
societies is you don't need the same
people to be technically in power to
have
exerting power I'm that's why what
happened with US Attorney scandal is so
disturbing there's evidence that the
emails the White House doesn't want to
disclose are going to show that there
was a discussion purging all of the US
Attorney's at once and I'm not surprised
they want to show those emails that's
what gurbles did in April of 1933 and
you know that in a closing society it's
a classic tactic you purge the civil
service of independent thinkers you
focus especially on lawyers and judges
that could gurbles good and then you
don't need a coup because in a close
election if that had happened it would
be the end of America essentially it
would be over because in a close
election the US attorneys are the ones
who have the power to go after
investigate voting rights groups and you
have the power to really in a closing
society you will still have election you
just won't have free election you don't
have uncorrupted elections are you
arguing a little bit too much here
because my memory serves right it was
President Clinton and an attorney
General Reno when in 1992 that
unprecedented
asked for resignation of all 92 US
Attorney's of what was contemplated that
in this case actually was effectuated in
in Prior times and I don't think that
was a that was a tipping point I think
that was just a natural exercise of
policymaking authority by a know
Victoria's president you know I totally
see your point and if this
administration and its enablers in
Congress Democrat and Republican weren't
so consistently dismantling checks and
balances I would agree with you but you
know when you ask what is the urgency
that's one more signal you know that and
the fact that I you know increasingly
people find themselves under
investigation if they give money
Democratic groups you know there's this
politician in prison in Alabama for what
looks like politically motivated
prosecution I mean it's the big picture
and when you say why's it so urgent
here's why
we're at a point where I mean if you
look at these are the cruising societies
they do something that's always the same
they start with torturing brown people
right they start with torturing people
who are defined as alien or other that
most of mainstream society doesn't
identify with Muslims non-english
speakers you know in Germany they
started with anarchists communists
homosexuals gypsies - okay but then what
they always do is one sec established in
one society tolerates that always they
start to blur the line always they start
to incrementally go after start to
arrest start to abuse people at the
heart of civil society and then at a
certain point there's a targeting or a
series of arrests and right now so I'm a
journalist so right now we have all the
pieces in place but the tomorrow morning
I could wake up and read in The
Washington Post that half of the editors
and reporters of Washington posts have
been charged under the 1917 Espionage
Act if they revealed classified
information or I could wake up and find
that the heads of move on and various
environmental groups and they appealed
you have been called enemy combatants
for for for their activities and you
know don't get out eventually or they'll
be able to talk to their lawyers
mentioned that for right now they're in
solitary confinement and if I were to
read that tomorrow this is how fast a
society closes down that when we're at
the point where out of these various
checks and balances being so weak
weakened destroyed when that starts to
happen when it starts to threaten
ordinary people like you should have
heard the conversations I had after the
tasering of the student people were
terrified people some people were saying
okay now I'm scared to speak up in
public and other people say no no you
have to speak up more now because it's
just going to embolden them but when you
start to have certain things like people
start I mean you could plot it on time I
extra told you last year that people
would start to get hurt for asking
questions by now because the blueprint
is predictive and so what is predictive
is even any executive it could be a
president Hilary and the founders knew
this absolute power corrupts and it just
keeps correcting it corrupts good people
that's why we put in place checks and
balances if you give any president the
power to round up people
and call them an enemy combatant and
lock them up then that's still distant
quickly after those arrests happen if I
read about it America will still have
the New York Times The Washington Post
will still have American Idol and
internet shopping what we won't have is
Liberty because I will not be having
this conversation with you
the week after those arrests take place
with all beaches scared my mother too
not that great
the President as he has asserted
Congress has acquiesced and the Supreme
Court is recognized
and as you criticized as a power to
arrest and detain persons including US
citizens as enemy combatants if they're
in school because the status is the envy
yeah but but the Supreme Court also has
I've in my view wisely set up procedures
whereby the accused person would would
be able to challenge the specific
element is that better of course but
that isn't that a reaffirmation that our
isn't that a reaffirmation of the of the
of the process and indeed even though
the president has very loudly a service
power there are only a handful three the
persons designated and in combatants who
are u.s. who are US citizens does that
does the natural check of the electorate
that's the natural respect for democracy
and the opinions of the people serve as
a way in order to constrain governmental
power and an official action you know
this is very scary because is you know
if the only thing restraining a
president any president from arresting
other US citizens as enemy combatants is
a his or her worry about the opinions of
the people or respected Constitution
yeah but the founders knew that opinions
weren't enough and that good wishes
weren't enough and the founders knew
that if you give anyone the kind of
power to intimidate and round up the
opposition they're going to use it I
mean you know the Federalist Papers were
written in a spirit that we need to
remember the founders were scared they
were scared to convey me without a
question that an American despot could
arrive in America
to oppress Americans they knew that any
American president or a despotic
Congress could start to round people up
and that's why they enshrined the due
process that's why they cared so much
about the right for American citizens to
to be heard and to be protected and to
not be locked up and abused and the
secondly on the same you is okay right
now it's three you have citizens who
were called enemy combatants and rounded
up but don't you find it scary that the
president has the power to say to make
that 12:00 tomorrow or thirty and let me
show you again from my study of closing
societies tipping points like this don't
take many arrests
if thirty journalists were called enemy
combatants tomorrow it would be over you
would you would have radio silence you
know that in Latin America in closed
societies people still publish
newspapers they still have radio they
still have TV a star of elections death
pits and closed societies hold elections
because that's a point of pride to them
what they do not have is Liberty and let
me ask you this you know no it's not
enough for me would you want to spend
three years in it fell ten by twelve and
Navy brig in solitary confinement with
people making it difficult for you to
see your family or talk to your lawyer
absolutely absolutely not and that's why
we require a system requires the
president come forth with articulable
evidence and requires the the ability
challenge that is indeed Jose Judy Jose
Jose Padilla was just convicted just
last month in not in a court of law
based upon the evidence that was
presented to that court thank God
although you didn't hear the original
highly touted charges well well sure
because because that evidence reportedly
came from
KSM and Dennis Eve and they did not want
obviously to produce a KSM and Dennis
even in court one question for you
though let me I'm not going to
respectfully I'm not to let you you know
make it seem legal in it one of the
final charge of judgment but a lot of
the final charging document did not
ended with the the with mr. Padilla
entering the the camp
none of it I wouldn't that is not my
point my point is that the president can
hold an American citizen for months or
years in solitary confinement well this
well this unfold and by that time
psychiatrists know mentally strong
resilient healthy people like you and me
or our families who fled oppression like
this go crazy because solitary
confinement drives you mad they knew
that installing gulag you know you've
got to take a look at the section on the
blog because Guantanamo is set up to
parallel what Stalin did with the glug
and the practices in Guantanamo the use
of dogs the use of extremes of heat and
cold the use of solitary confinement to
punish people the forced confessions
with standing positions stress positions
which Rumsfeld defended those come
straight from the gulag what question is
that my question is as follows let's
start from your very first which is a
very good point which is the invocation
of a real or imagined threat as the
first of your of your of your sent not
ten steps do you think the threat that
we currently face is a real or imaginary
threat and it is the or either is it
being misused by those in power
apparently including in order to not
justify but this supposed to assault on
massive liberties it's certainly a real
threat and it's certainly being misused
hyped distorted manipulated to in drive
through this agenda and I should share
with you what I think is the motivator
of the agenda you know America is not
driven by ideologies the way Mussolini's
Italy or Hitler's Germany stirred and by
ideologies with drive a big historical
notion America's often money and profit
and I think I think I've kind of found a
smoking gun we need to - enemy right now
for economic reasons I'm sorry to say
this because it goes to Hana Ren's point
about the banality of evil but you know
I think a third of the US economy is the
defense industry the weapons industry
and in when we had a Soviet enemy we had
a big strapping enemy that justified and
necessitated of course reasonably
this massive arms build-up with its
attendant profits to shareholders but in
the wake of the fall of the Berlin Wall
we lost that enemy and arms
manufacturers lost that enemy and so
they were really looking into the face
of declining market share for a world
essentially you know not riven by these
two superpowers are being at war and so
it is not uninteresting to me that in
the wake of attacks by al-qaida around
the world defense manufacturers began to
turn from cold war style weapon systems
manufactured to surveillance and
homeland security type technology to
build market share okay well if that's
what you're doing you see a way to grow
your industry it's not surprising to me
to discover I share with readers in the
end of America
that what's become what a member of the
Trilateral Commission calls the security
industrial complex now has their own
lobbyists it's a multi-billion dollar
industry Blackwater and other
contractors like raytheon-sarcos and if
you need to build this technology you
need to hype an enemy and the best way
to make sure to grow your market share
in the future is to make sure that the
enemy is us to build and build domestic
surveillance with the Wall Street
Journal I beg your pardon the New York
Times just ran a big set of stories on
how Wall Street is investing in the
Chinese police state because the profits
of surveilling and and doing police
investigations it's called a dangan that
the threefold dossier which this guy in
the government in the US government was
just describing to me is beginning with
civil servants here you know the work
life the family life the scrutiny that
follows you from place to place even as
you move huge process there so the West
is investing in the Chinese police state
investing in ever proliferating
surveillance of Chinese citizens well
it's profitable there it's profitable
here and so I think we need to notice
that there's a massive financial
incentive to hype the terror threat many
people are making huge fortunes you
brought up the example before the break
of England Spain and not
not and our European allies England of
course has had its own traditional
threat with the Irish terrorists we're
number he is now facing obviously a
current terror threat the report I think
that maybe quote in your book but
certainly but the official report counts
thousands upon thousands of civilians
cameras and even think the average is
that per average person gets a snap
three by thirty two cameras on and on an
average Saturday and we in America and
you are are you know in the you know and
then just a starting point of those of
those things Spain and other European
countries have traditionally for a
number of years and very effective at
using preventive detention I was
permitted in their law for a period of
months up to a year including and indeed
the UK adopted the same measure until
until recently we don't you know those
are much more dramatic much more drastic
measures in some ways or at least
comparable responses in other ways
why are we not seeing the same type of
criticism the same kind of concern and
so-called tipping point in those kind of
society why are we holding them up as an
example yeah I respectfully very much
disagree with you that those kinds of
actions are being deployed in a way
they're being deployed here it's clearly
you know I used to live in Israel and
Israel faces real terrorists every
single day and real terror attacks and
real explosions and people in Israel do
not walk around to the state of fear the
Americans are walking around and now
because the assumption is that Mossad is
doing its work and Mossad is quietly
doing its work and that when people need
to know something it's practical
information there's nothing like the red
orange yellow alert there that there is
here that would be considered insane
over there where the real job is to
catch and track terrorists so what you
get is like avoid London area which is a
market place you know on Friday
afternoon because there's real
intelligence and in fact Israelis make a
point of pride to not live in fear and
to not let terrorists
take away what makes civil society
valuable and I'm certainly not seen in
the country that you mentioned the
height threat of terror that the fact of
of the real terror threat being used to
drive a political agenda that
intimidates and coerces citizens the
book